[Music]
ahoy TV lovers I'm your captain slash
host Liana Galera and this is ship
worthy the only show devoted to
celebrating the most swoon worthy
couples on TV so come aboard with me
because in this episode I'm aiming all
of my attention at arrows perfect
partnership between Oliver Queen and
Felicity Smoak aka
all olicity now in addition to gushing
over this super couples best scenes in
naughty or nice I'm also bringing you an
exclusive brand-new interview with the
Green Arrow himself Stephen Amell
talking all about his undeniable
on-screen chemistry with Emily better
cards and why this couple always finds
their way back to each other probably
means that they're soul mates right but
for now shippers grab your favorite red
pen and get ready to take some notes
because it's time to take a look back at
how this action-packed romance first
sailed onto our screens and Anchors Away
now it all began back in Arrow's third
episode when Oliver sat the help of the
cute competent and often tongue-tied
Queen consolidated IT expert Felicity
Smoak hi I'm Oliver Queen of course and
their working relationship kicked off on
a fantastic start I was at my coffee
shop surfing the web and I spilt a latte
on it really yeah because these look
like bullet holes my coffee shop isn't a
bad neighborhood as their dynamic
evolved over season one the two began to
confide in each other and the og team
arrow was formed so why don't you help
us take him down
fast forward to season three when Oliver
finally asked Felicity the question we
were all dying to hear no not that one
this one Lissa's he would you like to go
out to dinner with me I'm being serious
here Oliver so my and that first date
was everything our little schipper
hearts could have asked for she looked
incredible he looked stunned and we even
gotten amazing callback to their very
first meeting it was just something
about him
it was read and of course we need to
talk about that amazingly epic and dare
I say TV's most highly anticipated first
kiss don't ask me to say that I don't
love you ah
the fields now after a near proposal
during their happy days in Ivy town
Oliver popped that other big question in
front of well the entire town of Star
City
happiest man
on the face of the earth
and despite all of this couples ups and
downs and the endless array of villains
coming in and out of their city olicity
finally and officially tie the knot
alongside a few of their best friends
Mary and Mary I love you fear in life is
losing you right yes okay yeah I do I do
um who else was all aquiver over that
big moment arrow pun for the win
now that we've shot through how Ola city
came together as a couple
let's take a look at some of their
sweetest and most sultry scenes in
naughty or nice
I'm haven't you saying that under
different circumstances very platonic
circumstances kicking things off with my
favorite nice moments we just saw Alyssa
Dee's I Do's but their vows at their
fake wedding for Cupid made me shed some
real tears whether you make me feel this
I also really loved their brief yet
adorably happy time in Ivy town this is
a smoke
you have failed this often any in all
Salmon Ladder references and the fact
that even though Oliver is the real-life
superhero it's actually been Felicity
who saved him on more than one occasion
now moving into the naughty list we most
definitely need to look back at their
first time together I love you now even
without all those candles in the room I
think we can all agree that that scene
was h.o.t hot
OMB season five flashback scene with the
Salmon Ladder which eventually led to a
steamy bunker rendezvous is just wow and
in my opinion this season foreseen had
an equal blend of naughty and nice
elements with adorable declarations of
love as we found ourselves in each other
and one of the most iconic kisses in TV
history now do you guys want more from
this chemistry charged couple yeah me
too so I recently sat down with star
Stephen Amell and asked him to spill on
all things
Felicity take a look at what he told me
this is a couple that has grown for six
seasons and been through so many ups and
downs why do you feel like they always
come back to each other it probably
means that they're soul mates right I
don't I don't know Emily and I have
always had a really nice chemistry I
think and it's always been so easy to
work with her so I think that Oliver and
Felicity will worked you know scorecards
don't have pictures so if you have
something on a TV show that's working
you should write towards it I've enjoyed
them in conflict as much as I've enjoyed
them settled and domestic and happy I've
enjoyed them as angsty will they won't
they and I I've enjoyed them as parents
to William so why do you feel like the
fans resonate so strongly with this
couple because you guys have one of the
most passionate fan bases I've ever
encountered yeah well I mean two times
ships of the Year Award winner off for
MTV no big deal I don't know what the
secret sauce is you know any time that
you can elicit a passionate response
from a group of people you're clearly
doing something right so I'm just glad
that we're doing something like Oh
Steven you guys are definitely doing
something right now it has been a joy to
watch these two courageous and
compassionate characters fight for their
city and for each other and evolve into
the Canon relationship of arrow in short
olicity you have not failed this fan
and there you have it that does it for
this first olicity episode of ship
worthy but don't worry as I continue to
interview Stephen Amell and Emily BETT
Rickards
we'll be back with follow-up episodes
about olicity and where their
relationship will be sailing to next now
if you guys had fun sailing with me
please give this video a like then drop
anchor in the comments below and tell me
why you love olicity as a couple Oh in
which naughty or nice moments hit the
bull's eye for you tell me plus if you
strongly ship any other TV couples let
me know comment or tweet me with your
nominations of who you think I should
feature in future episodes of ship
worthy and until next time bon voyage TV
lovers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]